étranger
nous nous asseyons tous depuis le matin
personne ne vois-tu personne autour de personne il n'y a
pas de client ils n'ont pas acheté
leur plainte de manque d'argent liquide
n'est pas dans la ville
[Musique]
étranger
aucun client ne vient
mais  ils ont préféré avoir de l'argent et
il n'y a pas d'argent
et c'est tout le sans argent Écrasez
tout ce que nous luttons, nous
luttons, nous pouvons voir
que c'est douloureux parce que nous n'avons pas vu mon
client de l'université, personne n'entre sur
le marché pour fixer le prix ou pour acheter pas d'argent je  je
me sens mal oui je me sens mal je ressens des douleurs
avec des larmes de Christ beaucoup de gens pleurent
il n'y a pas d'argent des gens meurent des
gens ont du mal à chercher de l'
argent mais où est
l'argent  nous
leur disons que ce que nous achetons sur le marché,
nous allons acheter parce que nous avons
des choses chères sur le marché, c'est trop donc tous
quand ils mangent, ils
nous supplieront de réduire le prix
il n'y a pas d'incendie il n'y a pas de faute à acheter
pour  ça part pour ton véhicule maintenant tu
sais que son essence est trop chère alors tu
sais que ça rend tout étanche
sans que je puisse voir qu'il y a de
la violence dans ce pays
pour le Nigeria
[Musique]
tu ne verras pas d'argent pour attirer l'étranger